We've all had moments where we felt
desperate to eat anything
But what if your only option was human flesh?
Most of us have heard of cannibalism
but what happens when you eat humans?
If we first look at insects, snails, fish or amphibians,
we can see that cannibalism is abundant.
For example, crab spider mothers lay
unfertilized nurse eggs for her spiderlings to feast on
and once the eggs are consumed, she offers herself
to be eaten entirely in the process called Matriphagy
But when it comes to mammals, cannibalism
is more rare; often triggered by environmental stressors
like when rabbits eat their young
under stressful situations.
French paleontologists found human examples
from 100 000 years old neanderthal bones
which showed signs of breaking
as a way to extract marrow and eat brains
and tool cut marks suggesting
that the tongue and thigh were eaten as well
But even in the 20th century,
medicinal cannaibalism was used in Europe
where human blood was prescribed as a remedy.
Which brings us to the first issue
Without proper care and preparation,
you run the risk of contracting any bloodborne disease
like Hepatitits or Ebola that your victim may be carrying.
As well the risk of infection from
the deceased's Ecoli and other gut bacteria.
Speaking of blood, we're definitely red meat.
This is due to myoglobin, an iron and oxygen
binding protein found in muscle tissue.
Your nutritional value?
Well your thigh is around 10 000 calories, your heart 700, and your entire body around 81 000 calories.
But about half of these calories come from adipose or fat tissue so you aren't the best meat for those on a diet.
And even though anecdotal accounts say
we taste somewhere between pork and veal,
and a cute culinary robot identified us as bacon
There's still an even greater risk
in something called prions.
Though not fully understood, prions are versions
of a normal protein that has had its shape altered
and not only loses its function but becomes infectious.
These distorted proteins can influence other
similar healthy proteins and change them as well,
causing a chain reaction and creating disease.
In particular, prion disease creates holes in the brain
giving it a spongiform appearance
and ultimately causing death.
But unlike viruses, bacteria, fungi or parasitic infections which contain DNA or RNA, prions don't,
meaning they can't be killed with radiation or heat.
These incredibly infectious prions could be present
in any nervous tissue including organs and muscles.
But are most common in the brain
and spinal nerve tissues
Meaning if you happened to consume meat
with prions in it, your risk of infection is high.
Eat the brain and that risk goes much higher.
In the 1950s, researchers discovered
that several members of the Foray people,
a tribal group in Papua New Guinea
were suffering from a disease
called "Kuru" or "Laughing Disease"
which caused those infected to lose control
of their emotions, then bodily functions,
eventually succumbing to death
It turns out that Kuru was a prion disease
which was contracted through their funeral practices.
The Foray people believed
it was better for the body
to be eaten by the people who loved
them than by worms or insects.
And though the practie is believed to have stopped,
the incubation of prion disease can take up to 50 years
meaning new cases could still reveal themselves.
So while eating human flesh isn't
neccesarily always bad for you
especially if it lacks prions,
doing so carries incredibly high risks
that probably aren't worth it.
Just stick with the steak, unless
of course you're not human in which case
there are a tonne of shocking animals
that practice cannibalism.
Check out our video on the 10 weirdest
cannibalistic creatures in nature here.
And subscribe for more weekly
science videos every Thursday.